the council
um only two days ago the nation came
together in silence to
reflect on this pandemic and also to
remember the
huge amount of people that were lost as
a nation and it's
quite clear really that there are people
here now that have lost
friends family neighbors colleagues
during this pandemic period and it'd be
remiss of us not to
remember them and in if you haven't
personally lost anybody
there are residents of this district who
are no longer with us they're very
important
they're well loved and it's important
that we remember them so i'd like you to
please join me
in a minute silence to reflect on a
pandemic and importantly to remember the
people that are no longer here
thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank you and
that's very much appreciated and
unnecessary so uh before we start
first need to do some housekeeping so
mayor first of all reminds you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you're not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use the
messaging
or chat function during the meeting
unless it's to report a cunery
or non-pecuniary interest or to notify
the chair
that you wish to make a proposal
that's if you're attending this meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair please
await your turn
if members lose connection to the
meeting they must contact the member
support officer
mandy smith as soon as possible as this
is a virtual meeting you will not need
to stand to address the chair
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except whether a confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you're also
consenting
to being filmed by the council and
possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the counselor members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded can
i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence thank you chair we
have received apologies for absence
from councillor phillips thank you and
noted
are there any declarations of interest
okay i can see none
so moving on to item three which is mc20
stroke 27
confirming the minutes of the meeting
held on the 18th of february
2021 for accuracy only now before we
start on this there have been some
issues with accuracy
which council of war boys and councillor
mansell have already identified
and those amendments have been made are
there any other
issues with accuracy
council matthewson yeah i've advised the
committee services that um the minute at
65.4
regarding the um esg which stands for
environmental social and governance
um the the um it's incorrectly
government and it should be governance
um thank you just thank you for acting
thank you and i'm sure it will be thank
you very much
are there any others so please use the
hands up facility that way we can sort
of keep a tab on who
is actually trying to speak thank you
in that case can i have a proposal
please
counselor field and as a secondary
i was prepared to second the meeting the
minutes i'll
allow your group the right to uh
propose them okay
i'm i'll be honest with you i'm having
difficulty in the handset
facility at the moment so we'll try and
get that addressed as we move along um
so i got counseling matthias and i
believe you're trying to propose
yeah i thought i might second the
minutes or says it was it no one's
proposed them yet all right i will
propose them
with the amendments that have been uh
notified variously by councillors
mansell
warboys and myself thank you
thank you very much and uh thank you
councilmember i guess you were trying to
propose your second see your hands down
now that's good okay so we do have a
proposal and a second day
i'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors can you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by
clicking on the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen
and selecting the attendance and voting
button the vote for the agenda item will
now show in blue
and please click that blue line to open
the vote thank you
could i just check that the blue line
doesn't mention anything
about the amendments to be made can i
just check that i am voting for the
minutes of the meeting
with the amendments that have already
been mentioned they're not written it's
not in writing i just want to check that
i'm voting for the right thing
yeah that that is correct and we can
make slight amendment just hang on guys
okay we can't change the wording that
you see in front of you
however please rest assured that it does
include the amendments
that were suggested and afforded prior
to this meeting so if you'd like to
continue to vote please
counselor amaroson are you able to vote
or would you like us to take your vote
verbally
hello uh i thought i did i did vote
but um it's four i'll try
thank you
chair that is unanimous
thank you and i mentioned the meeting
have been confirmed and will be signed
the next practicable opportunity
so we're going to move on to the leaders
announcements i'd like to invite
councillor morley to present
her update please
thank you i'm really pleased councillors
to be able to share my final
announcements ahead of the various
elections in may
i feel i should start however following
our one minute silence
by expressing my support for those who
have been directly and indirectly
impacted by the pandemic over the last
year
my thoughts and prayers go in particular
to those who have lost family and
friends across the world
and of course in particular to our
residents in mid-suffolk
i would also like to put on record my
huge thanks to all of our staff
our partners particularly the nhs police
and county council
and of course our fantastic communities
and local volunteers
who've worked tirelessly over the last
year to tackle kovid19
as you all know from the data available
to the public and all councillors
progress with the distribution of the
vaccine across suffolk
and particularly in mid-suffolk
continues to be extremely effective i'm
confident that all those who have not
yet been offered the vaccine
will do so in line with the government's
roadmap
i'm also confident that this will also
be the case for all second doses
and any boosters that may be required i
will continue to meet regularly with the
chief executive of the ccg
and through the regular local outbreak
engagement boards to ensure this remains
on track
the infection rates hospitalizations and
deaths continue to fall
in suffolk but it is essential that we
don't become complacent now
there is no such thing as a postcoded
world
but we need to learn to adapt to living
with
that is why it is so essential that we
have effective recovery plans
and in particular an economic recovery
plan
this work is developing well in line
with the timetable for the roadmap
out of lockdown and i will ensure it is
shared with all councillors
and progress reported to all councillors
during the pre-election period
which starts today
the council the cha excuse me
the chancellor's freeport announcement
which includes our site at gateway 14
is therefore really welcome news that
will inevitably help strengthen our
economic recovery
enabling our district to thrive rather
than just survive
as you have hopefully seen we are also
really pleased to have now launched our
business innovation network
this builds on the success of innovation
labs in stone market
which we helped fund and our inaugural
innovation awards
which we hosted virtually before
christmas
innovation forms a key part of our
economic recovery plan
and subject planning we look forward to
seeing a new
innovation center coming forward at
gateway 14.
with all of this in mind i think it is
important that i also take this
opportunity to remind our local
businesses
to recheck whether they are eligible for
additional financial support
from the government's kovid 19 business
support grant schemes
that close on the 31st of march 2021
i would now like to talk briefly about
our environmental progress
as we enter spring and with the gradual
improvement in the weather
it was reassuring to see our garden
waste services restart again on the 8th
of march
the service was paused for a short
period earlier in this year due to the
impact
of kovid but i reassure all of our
customers that they would not be charged
whilst this service was not being
delivered
more significantly i'm really pleased to
share the environmental projects which
we have been able to secure
with external funding the first
is 1.4 million pounds of government
grant that we have received jointly with
weber district council
for carbon saving measures at our
leisure centres and other buildings
cabinet has also now confirmed funding
of 300 000
for a pilot solar carport scheme at
mid-suffolk leisure centre in stone
market
match funded by the government's getting
building fund
the project will enable the council to
produce energy through our solar panels
to help
run the leisure centres as well as
provide battery storage
and a number of electric vehicle
charging points
the work is due to be completed by
spring 2022
the cabinet has also recently approved
50 000 pounds
to enable the council's transfer from
diesel
to hydro treated vegetable oil fuel
which will reduce the council's carbon
emissions from vehicles by up to 90
percent
i would like to highlight our community
impact and a number of community
projects which the council has helped
move forward
despite the impact of kobe covid and the
huge pressure that
this has placed upon our environmental
health officers
we have successfully prosecuted a
company selling baked goods
at various suffolk markets including
stone market the company in question has
been fined nearly 10 000 pounds for few
food hygiene offences including failure
to maintain high risk foods at safe
temperatures
selling unfit food failure to provide
adequate hand washing facilities
and failing and failure to protect food
from contamination
cabinet has also awarded 370 000 pounds
of community infrastructure levy
to support our vision to build
communities with bright and healthy
futures
this includes over 239 000 pounds
towards the expansion of mendelssohn
health center
to provide increased clinical space for
a variety of health care professionals
including clinical pharmacists
physiotherapists
chiropodists phlebotomists and
counsellors
it is hoped that this expansion will
encourage hospital consultants to have
outpatient clinics at the health centre
providing vital services for local
residents on their doorstep
and alleviating the need for them to
travel miles to the nearest hospital
sustainable travel options will also be
promoted with
patients benefiting from the
installation of two new electric vehicle
charging points and cycle racks
the council has also invested in a
number of health and well-being projects
across
through cell these include eighteen
thousand pounds
to help fund a running track at
gizzlings and gizlingam's
church of england primary school that
will be used for the daily mile
initiative
and by the wider community outside of
school hours for local clubs
sixty two thousand five hundred and
thirty two pounds for hawley
to improve and expand the wrong
classical pavilion
and to revitalize king george's field
this will support multiple local
organizations including the football
club
bowls club scouts royal british legion
and hawley parish council
and it was fantastic to see that the
work at the new
sixth form center at stone upland high
school which the cabinet supported with
2.4 million of community infrastructure
levy
has recently been completed
finally i have the real pleasure this
evening of sharing the fantastic news
that we've been shortlisted for three
different awards
at this year's iez awards these
nominations reflect the improvements and
innovation with regard to planning
enforcement
our virtual high streets program and
most proudly our shortlisting for
council of the year
for those who haven't already seen them
you can watch our chief executive and
other officers being
interviewed by easy online and our video
submissions this is a wonderful
endorsement for our council
for how we work for the priorities and
directions set by our councillors
and for the amazing skill and effort of
all our officers
the actual awards will be decided at a
ceremony ceremony which will hopefully
be
face to face in september
thank you chair thank you councillor
morley do we have any questions please
for councillor molly
yeah councillor ebert please
thank you very much chair and thank you
councillor morley um but firstly can i
i seem to be getting a lot of feedback
on through
the um speakers i'm not sure if it's
because
members have got uh not on mute um but
it is quite
difficult to hear quite clearly
um firstly can i just say
just on um with environmental health if
we
wanted to acknowledge john grayling's
fantastic service this council of 38
years
many of us have been here a while will
know the great job that he's done so i
just wanted to acknowledge that
and with regards to a question i just
wondered whether
with regards to electric vehicle
charging points
and ones powered by solar pv
whether the council will support um
those um tourist um destinations such as
all the car farm
and bail and rare breeds to have
electric vehicle charging points
in their premises thank you
i'm not aware that we are allowed to put
electric vehicle charging points onto
private premises but i'm happy to ask
officers to look at it
and i'll take that away thank you very
much thank you
thank you both uh i can see another
hands up so we are going to move on
thank you councillor molly
okay i'm going to receive notifications
of petitions in accordance with the
council procedurals please
thank you chair um please be advised
that we have received the following
validated petition
a petition with 214 valid signatures
asking the council to save the school
road oak tree in elswell
this petition will be dealt with through
the usual process thank you
thank you item six we're now going to
move on to questions by counsellors
in accordance with the council procedure
rules and i know we have a number
this evening so i refer you to the
questions from councillors in the table
papers
and i'll ask councillor matthewson to
ask his question to councillor morley
please
thank you noting that the endeavor house
release has a break clause
which can be triggered later this year
are you prepared to consider
alternatives to
mid-summit district council's
headquarters remaining in ipswich
until at least 2027
thank you council matthewson and
councillor molly to respond please
thank you for your account your question
councilman
i feel as though this is a question that
you have asked in different ways many
times and has been answered before
as you know this is one of the topics on
which your group and the conservative
group couldn't agree when we were
considering a coalition arrangement
after the last elections
this isn't an issue at the forefront of
my mind at the moment
i do not have sleepless nights thinking
about having our hq
endeavour house not least of course
because we haven't really been based
there for over the last 12 months
i do have sleepless nights about the
pandemic about the tragedy loss of life
about the devastating direct and
indirect impact kobe has had on so many
of our residents lives
about what we are doing to support our
residents and communities
about what more we could do about the
health and well-being of our communities
and our businesses
and about the other really important
issues facing our residents such as
those raised in council rotten's
question
and the wider safety of women on our
streets and in society as a whole
but i respect your right counselor
matheson to ask this question
and you wish to receive an answer
the break clause on the lease if we were
to exercise it would need to be
served by this time next year march 2022
as things stand i have no intention of
asking officers to exercise that break
clause
as you know we have successfully
negotiated revised lease terms that
phase the contractual increase
in service charge costs we have
successfully negotiated the
relinquishing of the lease for the
councillor area on the second floor
this has been backdated to to be with
effect from november 2020
and we are reviewing the other areas we
occupy so that we can build on the
societal changes that have come about
because of the pandemic
this will mean that we only occupy what
we need but also
that we have spaces to come together to
collaborate
and to be creative rather than lots and
lots of desks
we are reimagining the purpose of our
office space
ultimately ultimately though in answer
to your question
it would be wrong of me it would be
wrong for me to ever rule out
any options and so the answer to your
question
is yes but personally will take i
personally will take significant
persuasion to change my
mind to move away from all of the
benefits which drew us to move to
endeavour house
together with our clinical commissioning
groups and the county council in the
first place
i should also add of course as a
fortnight to my answer
that this is not a decision that
mid-suffolk can take alone
as our staff who are the ones that
predominantly occupy endeavor house
rather than us as councillors of course
also work for
and employed by faber district council
and so any such decisions will therefore
have to be made in conjunction with baby
district council
and with our staff foremost in our mind
thank you chad thank you councillor
mathewson do you have a supplementary
question
yes if if i could share yes i
think the um the answer seems to be that
it hasn't been
um ruled out yet but so
i what i would like to just ask as a
supplementary then is
that what plans are there for more
meeting places
for um members and officers out in the
district
coastal morley i haven't
ruled out anything and i haven't ruled
in anything
at the moment we don't need meeting
spaces
out in our district i'm happy with the
way things are progressing
but of course i keep an open mind on the
matter
thank you chair thank you both uh moving
on to question two councillor stringer
to councillor brewster please
thank you chair councillor brewster
given the agreed motion from suffolk
county council to
applaud the introduction of freeport
status
to gateway 14 clearly stating it will be
a net
carbon it will be a net carbon free
development
can the portfolio holder confirm what
will make
gateway 14 a carbon-free development
thank you
thank you council stringer councillor
bruce to respond
thank you guys for the string of that
question um
yeah we're we're applauding the fact
that the freeport
or the freeport will be on gateway 14 as
well
the aspirations of the freeport east
beard are to create a green energy hub
that will help deliver net zero
transport systems
and complement sustainable developments
across the freeport east area these
aspirations align from our desire for
gateway 14
to deliver a high quality viable and
sustainable development
with low carbon impact this ambition has
been informed
through our work with the greater
southeast energy hub
and bays on a zero carbon feasibility
study for gateway 14.
we are now reviewing the options
proposed in this report
and possible funding routes in order to
deliver this
on this aspiration
counselor stringer do you have a
supplementary question please yes i do
chair
uh thank you councillor brewster for
your explanation
uh and and answer the question uh i do
have to say though
there's a slight difference in language
between stating something would be
carbon free and i hope you'd agree
there's a clear difference in language
between state and something
will be in net carbon free development
and that we aspire to doing it
and would you forgive me for being for
then asking if we are going to make this
a carbon-free development
why did we not seek to put this site
forward
as a site for a grid serve filling
station when we had the opportunity six
months ago
thank you chair thank you councillor
brewster please
thank you i don't know why we didn't put
it forward for
the grid and i wasn't actually aware of
that
um but yes there is a difference between
aspiration and actual i believe we're in
the early
days of of doing this obviously there is
a planning
application in which uh i dare say
you've looked at and and uh
and certainly bwb there was this
um a pro it's a pre-app an
um energy consultation and but it
deals with a sustainability statement so
that is
already started and that is part of the
planning application
but we still need to ensure that
looking at the reports we've got
the best way to do it and there are some
recommendations within those i know
so we have got time at this moment and
we wish to make it
as zero carbon as we can
um and and i think we'll we'll
get that result
thank you councillors moving on now to
councillor otton
question to councillor flatman please
thank you chairman the impact
of the pandemic on families in
particular
on women has been drastic the rise in
domestic violence has risen to level
never seen before
the issue of child care and support were
completely ignored by the chancellor's
budget
what has the council done over the past
year to help women
and parents with young children
thank you councillor otton and
councillor flatman to respond please
thank you councillor alton i share your
concerns about the impact the pandemic
has had on women
and also more broadly parents with young
children
as i have said before i am immensely
proud of the support that our council
has provided to our communities over the
last year
and thank you for the opportunity to to
describe
some of that support specifically in
relation to women and parents
just over a year ago a multi-agency
steering group
led by suffolk county council was
created to address
violence against women and girls and men
and boys this steering group has
developed a strategy
and action plan to address domestic
abuse
sexual violence and sexual exploitation
as well as this strategy our comms teams
have
helped promote sexual abuse and violence
awareness week
through our social media we have
provided satellite accommodation for
victims of domestic abuse
and promoted both the domestic abuse
hotline and domestic abuse
outreach service our housing team
prioritize these fleet those fleeing
domestic abuse
and work across agencies to support
those
that we house in a broader sense we have
also helped address holiday hunger
through work in partnership with abby
croft abbey crop leisure
and projects delivered in stone market
and eye
chill chat and play is still being
delivered in stone market
by home start mid
and supports families ex experiencing
a range of moderate and complex mental
health needs
this will soon also be expanded to
provision in need and market
and in terms of wider financial support
we provide 3 000 to lighthouse women's
aid each year
in revenue grant funding and we also
gave them a capital grant
of a further 3 000 last year
home start in suffolk receive a revenue
grant of 9
000 and home start midwest
mid and west suffolk also received
thought 4
000 and of course you'll be aware that
we do also
provide citizens advice with revenue
grant funding
because there has been so much going on
i have only briefly touched on the
activity we have either delivered
directly
or influence but we'll also send
a briefing note to all counsellors after
this meeting
so that you can see more of the detail
behind some of the things i have
mentioned
i hope that answers your question
counselor otton but happy to have
further discussions outside the meeting
thank you thank you thank you councillor
austin do you have a supplementary
question
um yes just to say that i'm really
pleased to hear
the amount of work that has been going
on and certainly
from my point of view and i know the
rest of the councils we certainly thank
all of them that have been doing that
work however my question is that of
course
that work cannot stop because there will
be many
staff and residents who are facing real
problems in the coming months
so what actions are in place to help
women and parents to continue
with a successful life and career
well as we've talked about last um
council
a month ago we talked about our
our plans to rejuvenate the whole
district
and i'm sure that you have those written
down
and i'm sure once we have i send you
around
this this um briefing note on everything
that's going on
you'll be very pleased but happy to take
any other
um any other points after you've seen
that briefing note
thank you thank you chair thank you
councillors uh moving on now to a
question from councillor mellon
to councillor fleming please thank you
chair
in the council's carbon reduction
management plan we say that for housing
we will review policy and regulation for
energy conservation
reduction and efficiency to understand
how this can be standardized for the
council's new builds
and retrofits by quarter 3
2020 stroke 21
and for the proposed housing strategy
revised action
to prepare a broad specification for new
build council stock
to include consideration of passive
technologies and measures to increase
accessibility
by quarter two of twenty twenty twenty
one
so my question is this have these
targets be met and if not
when will they be you councilman
councillor fleming to respond please
yes thank you councillor mellon very
much for your question um
these come from our carbon reduction
action plan
and um my response to the first part of
your question
is we are reviewing policy and
regulation for energy conservation
reduction
and efficiency to understand how this
can be standardized
for the new builds and retrofits our
surveyors have attended and completed a
level 5 diploma
in retrofit coordination and risk
management
delivered by the retrofit academy and
domestic
retrofit by the bre these courses enable
the evaluation of properties within our
stock that are suitable for retrofit to
be identified and planned
officers as opposed to outsourcing
will reduce the time and delay along
with saving on consultants costs
in addition to the retirement training
we have embarked on a program to collect
up-to-date energy performance data for
every home
in our stock we're working with the
energy saving trust
to deliver a program of measures that
tailored to every
weber and mid-suffolk owned home across
the districts
the draft design guide for new homes
contains a section on retrofit
and we will be continually looking to
review and change this document
as the industry moves towards net zero
carbon homes
following past 2035 which is
the retrofit standard our program of
fitting energy efficient heating
continues and consistently involves as
technology improves
we've allocated a budget to energy
measures for our homes targeting
properties through the
fabric first approach recommended bypass
2035 with 1 million set aside for
insulating solid wall properties
we are continually assessing the best
approach to delivering these measures
working with the energy saving trust and
we will be able to target homes and
funding
into the future this is a new
development that will become standard
procedure
in the coming years um
i will now move on to answering the
second part of your question
where followed by the end proposed
housing strategy revised action
prepare a broad specification for new
build council stock
to include
counselor counselor fleming i think
you've muted yourself somehow
uh i'm sorry
i don't know how that happened due to
the impact of covet
this new specification piece of work
was placed on hold as officers were
redeployed to other areas deemed higher
priority
we'll be taking up this work again as we
emerge from the stricter lockdown
restrictions
and what can return to some form of
business as usual
a new target for this to be completed
will be later in
2021 2022
thank you thank you council mellon do
you have a
supplementary question i do chair yes
thank you
um i'm very grateful to councillor
fleming for her answer and to hear about
the progress
that's been made but does she agree with
me that the progress
generally on the carbon reduction
management plan has been slow and can
she also tell me when the next audit
of the council's co2 emissions will take
place
um i um thank you very much um i have to
disagree that
um progress has been slow i think we've
been progressing
um very quickly i think that
the steps we're taking are serious ones
they involve public money
and i am actually amazed at how fast
we're moving so
i cannot agree with you on that one um
i will have to refer to one of my um
my director possibly um cass clements
could
um reply when the next audit is taking
place um i believe these are done
annually but cass if you could confirm
that please
absolutely thank you very much chair for
allowing me to come in and thank you for
the question
so the um baseline reviews are done on
an annual basis
and they're normally undertaken around
may of each year so we'll be moving into
that process very shortly
and we'll absolutely as soon as possible
be publishing
the um the findings from that review so
everybody will be able to see
the transfer from our remissions from um
2021
and our emissions from 1920 previously
thank you very much thank you
thank you councillors uh moving on to
item 7m
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedurals
do we have any no chair we don't thank
you
thank you then we'll move on to item
eight which is mc2028 the overview
scrutiny committee report i'd like to
invite councillor wellam
to introduce this paper which is for
noting councilwell
thank you chair my report covers the
meeting in january 2021
at which the mid-suffolk over the
scrutiny committee
considered the draft general fund budget
and the four-year
outlook members resolved to ask officers
and
cabinet to take account of various
comments made at the committee meeting
when preparing the final draft for
consideration by
council committee particularly ask that
funding be allocated for planning
enforcement
and legal costs associated with planning
members then scrutinize the draft hra
budget
and ask that comments may be given
consideration
when preparing the final draft of the
hra budget
for submission to council committee also
recommended that
council approaches the suffolk
disabilities forum
to see if a mid-suffolk district council
representative
on that forum would be appropriate
and then on the 15th of february the
joint committee
carried out a review of the local
citizens advice service
we received a report from the corporate
manager communities
and a presentation from the chief
executives
of the three local citizens advice
following a lengthy session of questions
and answers and debate
mitsuh district council members
concluded that
a mid-south district council appointment
as observer to mid-south
local citizens advice would be
beneficial to the council
and and to the uh citizens advice and
would be welcomed by
citizens advice there are other
recommendations which were agreed and
they are set out on page 35
in full a particular
particularly draw attention to
the resolution in respect of the
three-year
rolling funding review that it be
subject to indexation on an annual
review basis thank you chair
thank you councillor wellam um using the
handset function
uh we'll see if there are any questions
so we'll start with councillor mansell
please
uh thank you chair um i would just like
to ask
uh councillor welum about the what his
views on the timeliness
of the minutes of the ovian scrutiny
committee because a lot of the things
that are reported in this particular
set of minutes were things that we
discussed at our last full council
meeting and it would have been
extremely useful to have had that report
then
thank you uh
thank you uh thank you councillor
mansell um
i believe that the draft minutes of the
january meeting i think
those are the ones you're referring to i
believe they were available to cabinet
for their february meeting
but the final minutes um have taken
longer to be completed
i don't know if the chief executive
could let us know if there have been
some delays in completing final minutes
we'll just hold off for a second
thank you thank you i'll just pause
there i had to
come off mutant and put my camera on no
i'm not aware of any delays
in the production of minutes uh clearly
if councillors would like to see minutes
produced
in a more timely way i'm sure that's
something that we can discuss outside of
the meeting
otherwise minutes are clearly produced
in time for the next meeting for them to
be prepared
and then approved rather than
immediately after the meeting
of course all of our meetings are
recorded which of course adds
significant value above and beyond the
minutes which purely capture the
the key points of the discussions
whereas the the youtube videos
retained uh on uh the online are
available for all to watch and contain
the entirety of
every debate thank you
council monster are you happy with the
reply
you're on mute yes uh thank you for your
reply
um i would just prefer to have
as a summary i have i haven't got all
the time in the world to watch
videos on youtube but uh that's my view
um
but thank you for answering it thank you
thank you are there any other questions
for councillor wellington
okay councilwell is there anything you'd
like to say as you
finish no no that's fine thank you very
much indeed
thank you councillor uh and that report
was for noting only
we're now going to move on to item nine
which is the community infrastructure
levy
sil expenditure framework third review
march 2021
i'd like to invite councillor byrne to
introduce the paper and to move the
recommendations in the
pastor byrne thank you chairman
um first uh i'd like to give you some
background to this report
um our community infrastructure
levy expenditure framework was
originally
adopted by the council in march 2018
since then it's been reviewed twice
through the work of a joint
member panel and it was also considered
by the joint overview and scrutiny
committee in 2018
and in 2019 the first and second reviews
led to changes to the framework and to
the communication strategy being adopted
in march 2019 and april 2020
it was agreed in april 2020 that the
sill expenditure framework would be
reviewed again
in october 2020 with any changes being
put in place before the next bid round
which is bid round number seven
in may 2021
it was also understood that the joint
member panel would remain
to inform the third review process
that third review has taken place under
the auspices of the joint member panel
um you you can read a bit more about
that in paragraph
1.3 of the report
this report to council and changes to
appendix a which is the sale expenditure
framework itself
and the strategy which is in full in
appendix b are the outcomes of the
review
the key recommend check are set out in
full in
in your report in paragraph 4.5
and i don't propose to read them out in
full but the main
changes involve uh the
sill expenditure framework um
which as i've said is set out in full in
appendix a
and they involve uh new additional
criteria for dealing with uh sill bids
from adjoining local authorities and
infrastructure providers
there are also syllabid requests
direct from schools that we made slight
change
on there are agreements to keep sell
expenditure framework
under review and that the joint member
panel would remain
to inform the fourth seal expenditure
framework review
and then there are the amendments to the
sill expenditure framework
communication strategy which is in
appendix b
and the recommended changes are also
listed in
paragraph 4.5 in full
um they recommend that
that we provide some clear key messages
on a fact sheet type basis to cover
different
aspects of sill for the website
they proposed continuing with regular
briefing sessions with members
and also parishes in line with the
requirements for
regular communication in the sill
expenditure framework communist
community strategy which is two events a
year
um there is an alteration of wording to
reflect that parish briefings will take
place in a virtual setting
uh with the delete deletion of
references to those in
those briefings being held in different
locations within both districts
so the key outcomes for all the changes
suggested by the joint member
panel are as set out in paragraph 4.6
of the report and these include new
additional
application forms determining criteria
and procedural training changes to
address sill expenditure
outside weber and mid mid-suffolk's
geographical boundaries
where such impacts warrant mitigation
also procedural and working practice
changes to ensure
that weber and mid-suffolk secure
section 106 monies or so
in respect of new developments which
which occur beyond the district's
administrative
geographical boundaries worthy this
impacts on paper and mid suffix
infrastructure
so that any gained contributions can be
invested in baba
and mid-suffolk infrastructure and we
will continue to
improve communication around sil
particularly for members and parishes
also to continue to keep the sill
expenditure framework
and the sill expenditure framework
communication strategy
under regular review
before i move the recommendations i just
want to say that
an exercise like this highlights very
clearly just
how complex a business managing the
community infrastructure levy service is
it is incredibly detailed and requires
the
application of very disciplined and
meticulous skills
we are very fortunate to have such a
dedicated team working on this most
important
aspect of our planning work and
fortunate indeed
to have christine thurlow leading that
team
i do thank you all most warmly for your
dedication to this work
and for the outputs you achieve
so to conclude i move that council
agrees these changes as detailed under
the
three recommendations in section three
of the report
um if you'd like me to read them out
german i will but
um i'm just happy to leave it at that
thank you
i am happy for you not to read them out
they are they're quite
in depth and they are available to
everybody to read
unless anybody's got an objection with
that and it's difficult you read those
recommendations
that's the way we'll move forward good
okay so can i have a second to please i
guess that's you councillor brewster
it is mr chairman thank you very much um
yes i'm very very happy to
uh second uh councillor burns from the
proposal
thank you okay we're now going to move
to questions
counselors you may ask as many questions
as you wish
however remember this there must be
questions
relevant to the subject and must be a
question so it's not time for debate
so with that in mind and the rules uh
let's go to councillor pratt please
hello sorry it took me a while to unmute
there thank you very much councillor
bern
um now i i understand um you know that
in in the review um there were
considerations
to include funding for sustainable
travel infrastructure
um but there seems to be maybe i haven't
taken enough time to read the
recommendations but there doesn't seem
to be much
of an obvious reference to that in the
recommendations
um so i just wanted to query that really
and to and sort of ask about
the um status of that decision thank you
counselor please um yes i think
the chairman if i may i i will ask
christine furlow to um
address that particular question it's uh
as i said before it's a very detailed
and
a meticulous piece of work and i don't
know the answers to
all all the various aspects to it so if
if you could call
christine furlow please yes uh christine
if you could help out please that'd be
really appreciated or whoever's gonna
replace it
tom just
sorry just put a proper background on
excuse me for that
um yes apologies uh christine has um
has been called away and unable to
attend the meeting so um i'm here in her
stead
um and unfortunately i don't have the
level of kind of forensic detailed
knowledge
um of the recent review that christine
brings but i can commit to
um councillor pratt that within the next
couple of days i'll get back to him and
have a detailed discussion about the um
the role of the seal framework
and how sustainable travel
infrastructure is
is provided for within it
thank you and thank you for jumping into
the breach uh next question then
councillor otton please
uh thank you chairman i'd like to refer
to page 167
um thurston railway crossing
i'd like to know just what influence
that
the department can have on organizations
such as network
rail when they have been offered
a seal bid of a hundred thousand pounds
and yet continue
to fail to come up with the project
which they have been being paid for
counselor burn and if you need
assistance from
tom please just just call him in i do
please that that would be a question
that i would need uh
notice to answer i'm afraid council
rotten so uh
and i think perhaps uh tom barker
might might give you the same answer i
don't know but uh tom can you help out
there at all
well certainly we can influence but we
can't control as
as councillor rotten um referred so the
the money for the feasibility study has
been
offered and as i understand it the
feasibility study is underway
but i'll investigate that and get back
to you again within a matter of days
against laurentan
thank you and could i just a very very
small question
i'd like to know if something quite dear
to my heart
is why public art is being excluded
from any sill bids i think this is
important and part of
um our you know
support for local artists
and our community
um yes thank you for that quick uh
question uh counselor um i i i take it
on board i take your point
i think it's something that um uh
the working group will uh will need to
consider or at least i'll make sure that
that joint member panel
does does does take that on board when
it uh
considers the next review that shows how
detailed i must have read the report
so thank you thank you uh councillor
passmore please
thank you very much chairman i don't
know whether i need to ask david or
tommy probably both on this
it really concerns the remit of the
community infrastructure levy and what i
was thinking about was
um if we look at some of these
challenges we face
as we emerge from the pandemic we've
already heard from council often about
domestic abuse but another big area of
course is the
difficulty of mental health provision it
affects all of suffolk and probably
norfolk as well
if it were the case that we needed some
more facilities for
helping those who suffer from mental ill
health and it was a suffolk wide one
a would that counters infrastructure and
how
would that work if it was a pan suffolk
facility for argument's sake i haven't
got one in mind i promise you that
um and getting contributions from other
areas that
um obviously have the community
infrastructure levy
you may want to come back to me at
another time on that tom yeah
it's it it's it's it's a complicated
and difficult question to answer yeah
and
uh yes indeed a pan suffolk um
pan suffolk facility like that we would
expect
that we would be only part partners and
obviously in the
provision of any funding and um
i i i suspect that would take a lot of
discussion and a
a fair few meetings to to sort out
um tom can you can you
uh throw any light on whether you feel
that
mental health provision or facilities
for
for providing mental health could be
regarded
or should be regarded as as
infrastructure that we could use still
for
absolutely um um through you chair i'm
happy to confirm that the health
facilities
are an inherent part of the seal
expenditure framework
they are detailed within our
infrastructure delivery plan in a range
of different ways
and mental health facilities are
as important as the facilities that are
available for
physical health indeed most health
provision would take a holistic approach
and
not seek to separate the two and
certainly
so seal could contribute to the
provision of those facilities
looking at a county-wide provision
suffolk um seal would uh
be able to provide a proportionate
contribution
towards the overall costs i think it it
would inevitably
be complicated because not all
authorities across suffolk
have the community infrastructure levees
so east suffolk
babur and mid suffolk have community
infrastructure levy
west suffolk and ipswich borough council
don't have the community infrastructure
levy
so those councils would need to
presumably explore
other means and other funds in order to
make the relevant and appropriate
contributions so that
everybody was paying their equal share
thank you very much tom good to hear
that once again with suffolk's leading
the way on this of course i'm sure we
all agree with it
thank you chairman thank you moving on
to councillor field please
thank you just a quick question to
counselor burn
um having been on the working party i
know that this document is as you say
exceedingly complex and anything but
brief
and i'm i personally am concerned that
some of the audience
may find difficulties with that
complexity and
length uh would you agree that in the
next review we should perhaps consider
whether we couldn't make it somewhat
more succinct
and less complex so that
as we just demonstrate we don't need to
ask questions about what it means
um if it if it were possible at council
field
i would say absolutely yes um
i think there is a limit to which you
can distill these things down
and it it is very complex
and i i'm not making i don't think i
want to make any excuses for it
for it being lengthy like that i know
that you're
you're um keen on on brevity and your
your contribution to the joint member
panel in that respect is
most welcome and i'm sure that we can
we can give it a good airing the next
time we we meet
um whether it can be achieved or not
ideally i in an ideal world yes i would
say
um we should we should try to do that
uh and we are making some attempts
to to make the as i said there's there's
some changes
that we're going to make new new
documentation which will appear on
on the website uh that is will be
designed
to do just that try and simplify uh the
explanation of the process
but um tom can you if
if i may chairman ask tom to um
give his views on that particular point
sometimes very value question i think
certainly and um again through you chair
um
i think it's it is really important that
we retain and maintain the detail that
sits behind it i suppose
it might be useful to kind of think of
the the the detailed framework kind of
like terms and conditions or something
like that and so
so the detail is really important but i
think
i i agree with councillor field that in
terms of
some people being able to interpret and
understand exactly what they can do
we should explore some form of executive
summary or something of that nature
so that people can get a broad overview
but then when they're actually making
bids it is
important to understand the detail and
that does sometimes require a kind of
forensic look
but certainly something that clarifies
and simplifies
perhaps as well as rather than instead
of the detailed work
thank you and tom thank you for your for
your input it's appreciated
um we've now moved to the end of
question i can see no more hands up so
we're going to move into debate
a reminder on this that counselors will
only be able to speak once
for three minutes and that period will
be timed so who wants to start the
debate
[Music]
yep uh councillor eber please
thank you very much chair and thank you
to um councillor berlin also tom barker
for your
your input there um i think as
um being from a parish that has um
benefited from still funding at this
most recent round
i just wanted to highlight the the point
that it
does take an awful lot of coordinated
work
um for um parishes or
community groups to um submit a
sill bid so um for example in our case
there was you know myself as district
council my fellow district councillor
keith welland
county councillor andrew stringer the
parish councils the
different groups from the royal british
legion the scouts
playing fields committee roles club
a football club you know coordinating
all of that
does does take a lot of work
and those groups involved have to put in
um considerable work in order to
actually
um submit a sill application
so i suppose that um you know while it's
great that have to that our
parish has been a recipient of these i
think there is there is a high
volume of work involved and
i want to be sure as well that we're
actually getting that funding out to
communities
we're we're bringing in a lot of sill
funding at the moment and um
you know it's not a question for now but
for when we get
to that stage of report at another
council meeting
you know are we really sure we're
putting back into the communities
the same amount of money that we're
getting in in terms of
of the frequency of funding
received and um ensuring that it goes
out to all of our
communities so i just wanted to to make
those
those points really and also finally
that if
um you know we this community
infrastructure levy was brought in
um some years ago now um and
you know i want to sort of be quite
confident that government isn't going to
change the rules
and remove that and talk about something
different instead while we're still
trying to get
funding out to communities thank you
very much chair
thank you councillor and moving on to
councillor mansell please
uh thank you chair um i'd just like to
say that that there is um
there is an awful lot in this um in this
report
and i'm not uh i'm not disputing
councillor fields um
wish to have it a little bit more
succinct i too um
and one for conciseness um but i i do
think that that we
as a council are are um
we're a little bit ahead of the game in
terms of our
um still expenditure framework um and i
think it's extremely pleasing
that we have um in our infrastructure
delivery plan
we have um community projects
and we don't know what they are we have
the flexibility within that idp
um for communities to apply for funding
um
from the sale funds um and i think that
that that
that is you know it doesn't it does i'll
i'll admit you know
i'll agree with councillor ebern it is a
complicated procedure to do so
but but i think it's great that we have
the flexibility that these community
projects can get the funding
um from from seal um and i think that
uh christine fellow and her team uh do
put in an awful lot of work and they
are willing to help communities uh who
do want to try and apply for funding
um but you know i will be supporting
this i think it's great that we've got
the flexibility to
to help um to help fund these projects
in the communities
uh amongst other things there are other
unknown amounts of money in our idp
um and it and it's great to see them
there thank you
thank you councillor are there any other
counselors that wish to enter the debate
i think i've just put my hand yeah
yes just to expand a little on the
question i mean clearly there
are some differences of opinion within
the working group which is healthy
and we have come to a conclusion which
is which is in this document so i will
obviously be supporting it
um the points i really wanted to make is
that while
complexity clearly doesn't discourage a
body like the county council bidding for
a school
clear clearly we're looking at the other
end of the spectrum where perhaps
parishes are trying to forward
relatively small projects
and i feel that the the sheer complexity
of the task
and the fact that they have to that we
insist on on
spade ready projects for instance they
need to get planning permission before
they apply
some of those things do discourage this
deployment of money to the community
which we're all looking for so just uh
sort of
notice that uh certainly in the next
phase of revision
or i personally will be trying to
forward a few of those things and hope
i'll get some cooperation
from other members but it's clearly an
excellent effort we clearly have a
a process defined and we clearly are
providing money for infrastructure which
could
which is what we wish to do thank you
thank you council field and the next
question uh the next
um is counselor mattison please
thank you chair yes the the um
the public are are continually um crying
out for
the the for infrastructure to match the
development
that's um rolling forward and um
it's i think inevitably it always feels
as if we're behind
the curve in delivering it but the um
nevertheless it's it's it's a welcome
way of raising money
for infrastructure and that's great and
certainly support the
um support the for paper um i do wonder
in terms of the complexity that that's
been talked about and the need for
succinctness and
and so on and so on whether whether that
can partly be achieved
by actually producing um or extracting
from it
a more a simplified
uh approach for for parish councils and
local groups in particular um where
where
quite a lot of what's required would not
be applicable
and um the sorts of things that they
want
are within a much narrower band and
whether we we could do some more in that
direction to make it easier for them
thank you
thank you councillor and uh moving on to
councillor passmore please
uh thank you very much chairman and i i
just think this is a
an excellent proposal i shall certainly
um be supporting and i don't entirely
agree with them
john matson saying we're always seeming
to be behind the curve and i perhaps i
should declare an interest because of
the um
funding given to the new um police and
fire station stone market but you know
these are these are really big projects
so they don't
just come along um all the time and
getting that ready
huge commitment from the district
council christine thurlow and the team
so you know let's look at this as a very
positive development
and also bear in mind that whatever
anybody says
a community infrastructure levy is paid
for by somebody somewhere
now you could say well it erodes the
margin of the developer
maybe but it also potentially puts the
um
cost of housing up and so we've got to
get the balance right and i think these
proposals
are very very welcome and i have
absolutely no hesitation in supporting
them
and i do want to make the point chairman
if i may to congratulate everybody as
um david burns said at the beginning for
what a jolly good job
everybody's doing here so um i hope
everybody in this council will support
it
thank you very much
thank you i can see no other hands
raised um so therefore
councillor byrne is there anything else
you'd like to add
um thank you chairman
no this is this this is a stage
a developmental stage of a process that
we
have been operating for barely three
years
and we have achieved an enormous amount
with it
um i'm i'm very pleased to to receive
suggestions such as we've heard tonight
about
simplifying um simplifying the process
for
for the smaller groups who haven't got
the
same capacity obviously as as the larger
infrastructure providers or
infrastructure requirements
um so we'll take those forward to the
next review
and consider them the the joint member
working uh the joint member panel
and um uh let's hope we can be
discussing
simpler versions for groups like that
more succinct reports etc etc
but as i say it's um
it is a complex very complex and we have
to uh
we have to display a considerable amount
of due diligence when we're
looking at these uh bids there's quite a
lot of money involved
and we've got to make sure it works hard
for us
so thank you thank you and um
there's a theme there isn't there we it
is complex and uh the amount of detail
in this work and the diligence
by yourself by the offices um it should
be noted
so thank you all for for producing it
we're going to move on to the vote but
as i've said i'm not going to read out
the recommendations for this one because
they are quite lengthy
unless anybody wishes me to do so and if
you do then please raise your hands now
good okay i'll now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair um councillors the vote
is now open
please can you um click click on the
agenda item
it's now showing in blue to open the
vote you may need to scroll down
thank you
chair that was a unanimous vote thank
you
thank you that is carried moving on to
item
10 which is the mc
20 30 response to the consultation on a
future
of new homes bonus i'd like to invite
councillor whitehead
to introduce the paper and to move the
recommendations of the report council
whitehead
and thank you chairman i'm pleased to
introduce report mc2030
the response to the consultation on the
future of new homes bonus
which starts on page 181 of our report
pack
the long-awaited consultation on the
replacement for new homes bonus
was finally published by the ministry
for housing and
housing communities and local government
on the 10th of february
with an eight-week consultation period
now under the council's constitution
consultation responses are normally
delegated to the relevant
assistant director however the
monitoring officer has concluded
that this consultation is of sufficient
significance
for it to be referred to full council
for a response
due to the short time scale offered by
the ministry it was not possible for
officers to prepare a draft response to
be considered at our meeting today
so it is proposed that a joint
cross-party working group is established
to agree a response with the assistant
director for corporate resources
for submission by the deadline of the
7th of april
the proposed membership of the group is
set out in paragraph 4.6 of the report
however i understand that an amendment
to the competition of the baba
membership of this group
was agreed at baber's full council
meeting on tuesday evening
to include a representative from a
planning perspective
the baba competition will now be
academic member for finance
the cabinet member for housing who are
both conservative the cabinet member for
planning who is an independent
and a green party counsellor finally i
should also like to remind
all counsellors i set out in the report
at paragraph 4.7
that they are entitled to make their own
personal response to the consultation
should they so wish i'd like to propose
recommendations set out in three one and
three two
would ask for a second and as always i'm
happy to take any questions
thank you chair thank you councillor
whitehead
and i can see that the second is
probably going to be councillor
headingham
um yes i'm happy to second this
thank you we'll now move to questions
and again
you are allowed to ask as many questions
as you wish however they must be
relevant to the subject
under discussion and must be formed as a
question
not debate who wants to start
we have nobody wishing to ask questions
so we will move on to debate um
with the debate you're allowed to speak
once for a period of three minutes
and this will be timed who'd like to
start debate
a couple more seconds
okay it seems nobody wants to enter ah
we have one
uh counsellor feel please it's like
asking volunteers to go over the top
with baynet's fixed isn't it
we get there eventually you have more
experience than that
perhaps than i but but
we can't let you escape without any
debate um
it's just you you're defining quite an
acceptable process in many ways i i
would just
slightly concern that if you said this
was launched in february it's now march
that's what about six weeks away
you seem to have about two to three
weeks to to the
the end date so presumably um things
have moved forward quite a bit
it slightly concerns me that obviously
um
you know certain members of the of the
opposition and of the um
ruling party if you call it that will
will will be involved but
uh concerned that the rest of us will
hear
nothing until it's a done deal
is there any intention for any form of
communication
recognizing the hazard that always
brings of lots lots and lots of comments
well i'd anticipate before it was
submitted that it would be
circulated to all members and perhaps
kathleen steele could just
confirm that approach
thank you chair um i'm not sure that
we'll have time to
circulate for comment uh say we've got
uh just under two weeks now until
so the intention obviously was that the
nominations would be agreed at council
and they would be delegated the
responsibility
um there will be an opportunity i'm
trying to set up two meetings so we have
two stabs at it so there will be an
opportunity for people to talk to
other group members in between those
meetings to get further views if
necessary
but i think we're going to be very tight
in time in terms of uh circulating it to
all councillors
more fyi really okay
thank you um we'll move on to calcium
matheson please
thank you yeah looking back across the
last couple of years
we do seem to have got into
difficulties and contentions and so
forth
quite several times on on government
consultations
and i think it would be quite helpful if
the monitoring officer
could circulate not now but could
circulate
some some considered
general advice so that officers and
the administration and and the
opposition um
were clear as to as to how these matters
will be dealt with because
clearly in this particular case um
as councilfield has said it hasn't been
dealt with basically
until the last minute which is
unfortunate
thank you councillor do we have
anybody else that wishes to join the
debate
counselor phil can you take your hand
out please
all right okay councillor whitehead
uh appears nobody else is entering
debate do you have any anything else to
add
nothing further to add yeah thank you in
that case i'll now ask the corporate
governor
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors the vote is
now open please can you place your vote
thank you
counselor brewster are you having
problems um
actually it's just come through thank
you
chair that was unanimously full again
thank you that is carried moving on to
item
number 11 mcslash 20 31
which is pay policy statement 2021 22
and gender pay gap um there's a slight
typo there
i'd like to invite councillor whitehead
not councillor morley to
introduce this paper and to move the
recommendations in a report
council whitehead back to you thank you
chair
i'm pleased to introduce report mc2031
the pay policy statement for 2122 and
the pay
get gender pay gap report which starts
on page 185 of our report
we're required by the 2011 localism act
to prepare and publish a pay policy
statement
that is approved by council and by the
2010 equalities act
to report our gender pay gap the latter
does not have to be approved by council
as the two councils have a single
organizational structure with harmonized
pay
grades terms and conditions of service a
single pay policy statement is produced
which covers both councils
last year the state was contained in the
budget report in february 20
but due to the recent changes the senior
leadership team announced by the chief
executive last week
it was not possible to reflect these
changes and meet the timetable for the
february council meeting
and hence it's been presented to council
today
paragraph 3.3 of the report sets out the
key information that is contained within
the statement of appendix a
and a paragraph 3.4 highlights the
changes made compared to the statement
for the current year
the gender pay gap report is normally
published by the 31st of march each year
but due to the impact of covid the
deadline has been extended to the 31st
of october for 2021
so the report is not yet available as we
are two sovereign councils
a gender pay gap report has to be
published for each council
but the combined data is more relevant
due to our workforce being fully
integrated
and some of you may have spotted that
within the risk section of the report
the first and the third risks are
repeated and that's clearly an error
it's only only been in there once unlike
proposed recommendations set out in 2.1
and 2.2
would ask for a seconder i'd be happy to
answer questions that you may have and
with us today
are suzanne hughes our head of hr and
organizational development
and that many of you will not have met
before as well as catherine steele
assistant director both will assist me
with this
thank you thank you can i have a second
to please
uh counselor at penn young uh thank you
chair
i'm happy to to sir to second uh
councillor whitehead's proposals thank
you councillor
and uh yeah going back to council
whitehead you may use those offices to
support you in answering these questions
i know it can be quite detailed
so we will move to questions um and
again as before you can ask as many
questions you'd like but there must be
a question relevant to the subject and
posed as a question
so let's move on straight away with
councillor mansell please
uh thank you chair um i'd just like
councillor whitehead to clarify
what he just said about the gender pay
gap report because
i tried to click on the links in the
report of
our council meeting and discovered that
baber district council had something
under the link
for gender pay gap report and we didn't
and when you click on the one that's
listed under the baby district council
papers
on that webpage uh you come up with a
report that looks like it's got both
babe and mid suffolk in it
uh and council whitehead just said that
they had to be treated separately so
um could you just please explain to me
uh maybe i've
read it wrong councilor whitehead please
yes well
my understanding is that the report
hasn't yet been prepared so
and i must confess not expecting it to
be there i haven't even tried to click
on the link
myself is a 2019 report
but i was just looking to see what it
was really yeah that's last year's one
so this year's one
you know has been delayed and will be
available before
prior to the deadline and it and it is
going to be a separate one is it
did you did you say baber and midfield
had two separate ones
let me just remind myself for just a
moment
uh from myself what i said um yes we
have to repair
two separate ones but then there is a
combined one two
of data which basically is a more
relevant one i'll bring in the ceo
off please
there we go i think i'm off mute um
thank you chairman
yes as council whitehead said we're
obliged to publish
as separate organizations agenda pay
report
for each council but of course it's a
nonsense
because of the way in which we operate
and so what we would tend to do is
contain that within the same document so
you'd be able to
read the baba figures notionally and the
mid suffix figures notionally
but more importantly be able to see them
together so that we both comply with the
law
but more importantly we also can't
comply with common sense
uh and they will be linked from both
sections
of that web page not just the labour one
absolutely of course yes
the website itself obviously has
different uh front skins
in terms of the the addresses a lot of
the content is the same but yes you'd be
able to access it
from the www mid-suffolk webpage
thank you for the clarity okay we'll
move on now to councillor geek please
thank you chuck can i just um say that
we do have an awful lot of links on our
website
labeled as baba not mid suffolk and it
is very irritating to have to come
to explain to residents but my question
is
why if we know the data on the gender
pay gap if the
if if it's already been prepared why is
it not being published
i mean it says in in paragraph 1.19 that
it has been prepared so if the work has
been done
why isn't it there for us to read it it
doesn't seem
sensible if the work's been done to say
oh well covid
that's caused the delay the work's been
done surely
councilor whitehead well there is a need
as explained
to then effectively consolidate two sets
of data
from the two separate councils but
beyond that and
rather than just having it's as well
being just a data dump if you like
there is the narrative and explanation
behind it and also
i think it gives the slt chance to sort
of look at that and
and see what what they can learn from it
as well but again
if either ceo or catherine steele wants
to just add to that
explanation
or not
there we go that took an inordinate
amount of time
simply for me to say i don't think
there's anything i can add but thank you
guys
i don't know whether catherine wishes to
i don't think but i think you covered it
thank you catherine
no thank you chair i don't think there's
anything i can add to that either thank
you
well i'll just restrain my own patience
then thank you
look forward to this summer counselor
please
you very much chair and thank you
councillor whitehead for that report um
i would just
um uh like to ask again i'm sorry to
labor the point that
um councillor mantle has made but when
you go to the transparency section of
the website
it does say under mid-suffolk there is
nothing the gender pay gap
so please can we fix this in advance of
this
document being the gender pay gap work
being prepared
as otherwise anybody looking at our
website
would think that um only baba is
concerned about
gender pagar and and not with suffolk
and as it is a requirement
i think that that web link does need to
be fixed
um but secondly um with regards to
the um gender pay gap um
report will this be circulated to all
members
um when it's available and not just on
the 31st of october thank you very much
chair
thank you alex the ceo is going to come
in on this one
i got in in advance on that one because
i thought it might be helpful
rather than waiting to come in yes
absolutely we'll make sure it's
circulated to all councillors
at the same time that it's published on
the website and yes we'll go away and
look at that link to make sure it's
fixed
thank you very much thank you all um
councillor otton please
um yes um as a result of that
i am somewhat confused because you state
that you do not need to do an equality
impact assessment
because it's the same as last year but
if you
can you just explain if if you haven't
got the report
then how can you categorically state
you don't need to do a eia
back to the ceo thank you chairman i
don't know whether council whitehead
wanted to answer it but rather than me
jumping in but if not
i'm happy for you to answer that one
that's very kind very kind of
um yes the predominant uh subject for
this report
isn't the equality uh statement the
gender pay cap statement sorry
it's the pay policy so when there's
reference to
the equality impact statement that's
referring to not the need to do so in
relation to the pay
policy and hence the that statement
uh clearly the very nature of a gender
pay gap
needs to be assessed in terms of any
equality impact
and more particularly in terms of not
just what our gender pay gap
is but more specifically the actions
that we'll be taking as a result of that
because the action plan is
bluntly more interesting and more
significant than the statement of the
the data so clearly that will take into
account uh any
equality impact issues as part of that
exercise
so will that report then be available
sorry i was too quick there turning my
camera off um the
equality impact assessment yes
thank you
i can see no more hands up for any
further questions so we will move to
debate
um each counsellor will be allowed to uh
debate once
uh it's for three minutes and you will
be timed
don't keep me waiting this time who
wants to start debate
okay we'll give you a few more seconds
just think about it and then we will
move on
counselor autumn please
you're on mute counselor yeah could i
just clarify then
that what we actually voting on
if we haven't actually got the report
council whitehead if you could be
specific please yes
we are voting on the
pay policy statement and also
noting that in due course the gender
pay gap report will be available online
and by the deadline
well voting on the recommendations are
set out
in those paragraphs 2.1 and 2.2
because you wish to answer debate
no that's fine okay thank you and uh
councillor mansell please
don't mute uh thank you chair sorry if
i'm being a little bit
uh dense um but uh recommendation 2.2
states that the publication we are
recommending to the recommendations to
council the publication of the council's
gender pay gap as of the 31st of march
2020
be noted but it hasn't been prepared yet
so i'm not quite sure
how i can note it when i haven't seen it
see you please yes apologies if that
word is
wedding is confusing in any way you're
effectively noting
when it's going to be published
i'm just going to bring emily ewell in
as well which will assist us with this
emily
thank you chairman i wonder if the
recommendation 2.2
might easily be rectified by adding
in the words after that um
the delay to the publication um so if
those four words
the delay to the publication be be added
in that would then make
the recommendation more logical in terms
of the
delayed publication date that we've
heard about in the report
thank you chair thank you i'll go back
to the proposal in a second
please thoughts well
to be honest i did wonder myself whether
some extra wedding might
be usefully added in uh prior to prior
to
to the meeting so yes i'm more than
happy to to take those on board
and secondly please i'm also happy to
take those on board mr chairman
thank you um we're just going to rewrite
that 3
2.2 and then we'll move on shortly does
anybody else want to
enter debate
okay nobody so what we're going to do is
going to take a quick pause which is
going to reword
uh 2.2 and then we'll move on so bear
with us
um chair the voting is is now ready it
has been amended to read
as amended by the monitoring officer and
detailed in the report so if councillors
could now go to the vote and place their
vote please thank you
chair thank you that is 32 4 and one
abstention
thank you thank you that is carried
um before we go on to um item number 12
we're going to take a five minute recess
uh just stretch your legs
to get our minds back and give us some
water so
be back in five minutes please
welcome back everybody uh we're now
going to move to item
12 which is mc20 32 the appointment the
independent renumeration panel
i'd like to invite the corporate manager
for governance and civic office to
reduce
the paper
thank you chair the current panel that
was appointed in 2016 has now reached
the end of their term
under the local authorities members
allowances england regulations 2003
the council is required to establish and
maintain a panel known as the
independent remuneration panel
to make recommendations and amendments
of the members allowances scheme a
recruitment exercise has been undertaken
candidates were selected from applicants
who had made a formal application
and underwent a competitive interview
council is therefore asked to approve
the formal appointment of the
recommended panel members
for four years with an option to extend
this for another four years
and also to confirm the fee payable for
each review
and the payment of reasonable expenses
happy to take any questions chair
thank you and can we have a proposal
please
i'm happy to propose chair thank you and
i guess
council bruce you're going to second i'm
happy to second thank you very much
okay um we are going to move on to
questions
uh and again as we said before you can
ask as many questions as you like
but it must be relative to the
discussion points
so who would like to ask any questions
council the ebern please
thank you very much chair and thank you
jan for that
um introduction um i just wanted to ask
if we know when a review is likely to
take place thank you very much
chair yeah we're hoping to start the
review as soon as possible
um so that we can get the timing in to
get recommendations to council by
hopefully the end of the year
to allow for the correct timing before
the next um district election
thank you uh councillor stringer please
yeah thank you thank you chair i was
slightly alarmed at that answer i'll
explain why
uh voting on your own uh
allowance is is probably one of the most
damaging things you can do as a
counselor i hate doing it i don't think
i should be put in the position to do it
because i feel i think while in an
office to vote on what you should be
given
for doing the job you're doing without
there being the chance for the public to
vote on it i think is
is wrong uh and the timing of
precluding that position is in our hands
at the moment i don't i can't speak for
other members here but i can honestly
say the casework
load that i have during the pandemic has
been
exponentially large so for someone to do
a review of the work i'm doing right now
would give a wrong indication of the
whole of the term
um so
sorry is it is this a question yes it is
yes okay
it sounds like debate to me so let's get
to the question okay
the question is can we make sure the
timing of the review
means that the last action of this
council's term is to vote for any
raise or otherwise in allowance
so that the public get a chance to vote
in between
that allowance being levied and those
needing to go through an electoral cycle
before they can
claim it thank you chair thank you
thank you chair if i could just come
back on that um councillors
the reboot can be undertaken at any time
but counsellors could choose to
implement
a delay on any um recommendations that
they wanted to
um agree and i just come back on
can i just come back on that yeah that's
still that still means
that we are voting while in the term for
our own race
i'll just make that point thank you
thank you are there any more questions
you've gone silent okay oh
sorry my apologies it's my microphone um
so we're now going to move to debate uh
you can each speak once
you will be timed you have three minutes
who would like to start debate
counselor geek please
thank you chair um i would just like to
say that i will be voting
for the recommendations for appointing
this panel but i'd very much like to
second
councillor stringer's point that we
should not
be timing this within the term
that we are elected for it should be the
last
action of the council and that should be
standard procedure so i would like to
second him on that
thank you anybody else wish to enter
debate
i'll give you a couple of seconds before
we move to the vote
okay and jian would you like to add
anything
no i have nothing else to add thank you
chair
thank you in that case we'll move to the
vote i'll read out the recommendations
on this one so we're clear
uh before we go to the vote the
recommendation is 3.1
that the following persons be appointed
to the council's independent
renumeration
remuneration panel amanda orchard
cereway
monica calpio john clough
and sue putters that the irp members
each be paid 500 pounds for each review
carried out
and reimbursed any expenses reasonably
incurred
in the performance of their duties and
3.3 that the irp
be appointed for a period of four years
with the option to extend this for a
period
another period of four years if required
and i'll now ask the corporate manager
governance civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors the vote is
now open if you'd like to proceed to
make your vote thank you
chair that is 32 4 and one abstention
thank you thank you
that is carried moving on to item
uh 13 council appointments are there any
changes to policings
yes yes chair thank you very much i'm
really pleased to announce that um
councillor paulek pengnong
has been appointed to the board of
gateway 14
and also that councillor harry
richardson
has been appointed as cabinet member for
health and well-being
thank you thank you councillor
we'll now move to agenda item
14 which motions on notice and before we
go on to this
you may have wondered why we're going to
the vote on this and therefore i'm going
to invite emily ewell
to explain the reasons emily
thank you chair yes i have had some
queries about whether this motion
relates to a council function or an
executive function
so i'd just like to provide some clarity
if i may
the actual review of green space is an
executive function therefore it will be
the role of the cabinet to determine the
format of the review
and to oversee its progress however in
voting tonight the council is expressing
it
whether or not it supports the principle
of undertaking
a review and if the vote is in the
affirmative the matter is then passed to
the cabinet to take forward
thank you chair thank you that's very
clear
so we will move to 14a which is
considered a motion on notice
received from councillor ebern
councillor eben please
thank you very much
this is a motion that the council
carries out a review of green space to
ensure that it is optimizing the
biodiversity
and well-being aspects of natural and
immunity green space in mid-southwest
during the last year the importance of
green spaces to our communities
has been highlighted with more people
than ever taking advantage of local
outdoor space
green spaces are important for many
reasons
for health both mental and physical we
know that social prescribing can work
that people with access to green space
live healthier lives that exercise is
beneficial
and the time spent outdoors improves our
mental health
as green lungs in the center of towns
where homes have small or no gardens
access to green space in our towns is
vital it provides areas for exercising
for dog walkers for nature and an area
to combat pollution
green spaces are important as wild
spaces for children to run free
when so much time is spent in front of
screens whether for play or for school
children need an outlet for their energy
which is unrestricted
an area where they can create their own
play and just be
in nature and green spaces has areas to
attract
visitors in our villages green center
pieces
full of wild flowers that inspire
visitors to stay awhile
and make our residents proud
as areas for wildlife for wild flowers
for greater biodiversity
in responding to the climate emergency
we should be prioritizing
areas for biodiversity ensuring there
are ponds trees
hedges areas of rough ground habitat for
all types of creatures and plants
and green spaces as areas of historical
importance
pieces of land that have historical
significance
that are found on old tithe maps and in
local histories
but also simply for their beauty and
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
a rough scrubby patch of land can mean
as much as a wildflower meadow or a cops
of trees
we should be creating new opportunities
for green spaces to positively look
for new areas and where there are gaps
but it's not just about green
spaces per se but about the availability
of them
and access to them in our rural area
people often have to travel
more to get to a green space natural
england proposed a standard for green
space provision
that everyone wherever they live should
have accessible
natural green space no more than 300
metres
or five minutes walk from home
and this does not refer to privately
owned farmland or footpaths but publicly
available
and accessible areas they need to be
accessible
the ability for a parent with their
toddler to be able to walk to
for someone to cycle to for a wheelchair
user to access
we cannot exclude anyone from this
and where we have green spaces we should
be looking to enhance them
improving biodiversity improving access
letting them work for people
these spaces should be publicly owned by
the community by local councils
even by the district council covenanted
so that no development can ever be
undertaken on them and finally we need
to protect the
spaces we do have ensure that our green
spaces are
designated as such as local green spaces
as defined
in the national planning policy
framework and set up a directory of
local green spaces and add to it
each year the council has already agreed
to draw up a supplementary planning
document for green spaces
in new developments but this motion is
about our existing green spaces
enhancing them protecting them and
finding new spaces in our towns and
villages
ultimately we need to value green space
more our communities have shown that
they both need and value them
green spaces are incredibly important
for health
mental and physical as green lungs in
the center of towns
as wild spaces for children to run free
as areas to attract
visitors as if there is for wildlife for
biodiversity
for their history and simply for their
beauty
as councillors we need to ensure that
the council works for our communities
and supports them in areas of importance
to them green spaces and access to them
is one such area
we need to put more effort into this
into showing our communities we're
listening
and that we value what they value a
review of green space in mid-suffolk
should bring this to light and lead us
to action in this regard
i have great pleasure in commending this
motion to you and i
would really ask that we could have a
unanimous vote for all councillors in
favor of it
but firstly i would like to ask my
colleague councillor fleming to second
this motion
and i'm most grateful to her input in
this area
thank you chair thank you councillor
byrne councillor fleming would you wish
to
second yes thank you
um chairman and thank you councillor
ebon
um i am very pleased to second this
motion
and um if you would like me to speak now
i can
i can i can go ahead yes you can or you
can reserve your right since i look to
you
um i'll i'll say what i need to say now
thank you
um i think councillor ebon and i clearly
agree
that there are many reasons why
accessible
natural green space or ang as it's
called is important
i think she's mentioned the important
things health and well-being
mental health physical health wildlife
education sports clean air
and happiness open space conveys
a sense of well-being and permanency
that is fundamentally reassuring
in a world which is becoming
increasingly stressful
and hurried the mid suffolk and baba
open space study which was prepared in
2019
supports our joint local plan
this refers to a number of largely
aspirational standards for accessible
open space of various kinds
allotments recreational space parks
and woodlands the um
the standards for open space have been
involving since 2003. and the
implications of putting
these aspirational standards into a
working practice
of complex and i believe that they
should not be overly rigid
i think the our approach to implementing
this motion
once we get to grips with it should be
twofold
firstly we need to review what we've got
the open space study of 2018s contains
a lot of information if anyone has a
chance to look at it
about the types of green space that we
already have
ordered by parish and is an excellent
starting point
but we need to take that further we need
to put plants in place
to optimize and use these assets and
identify gaps
understand what type of open space may
be needed
to supplement what we've got and take
into account the new planning context
growth pressure the pressures of
biodiversity loss and link these with
our emerging health and well-being
strategy
the open space study suggests several
strategic options
existing provision to be protected
existing provision to be enhanced
opportunities for relocation or
redesignation
etc etc and
i think one of the implications of
the open space study is
that we need to think carefully about
how we define open space itself
the open space definition used by
natural england is fairly rigid
and has some problems of practical
application particularly in areas
of mid-suffolk that are rural and
actively farmed
to conclude i feel that this motion
gives us the impetus to take action on
the objectives in the existing open
space
study and the emerging jlp it is
acknowledged that
a supplementary planning duckling
document
is the best way to set out how the
standards should be interpreted and
applied
i would like to see joint arrangements
in place so that the health and
well-being
aspects of open space are fully
considered as well
and i'm confident that this will be the
case thank you
thank you councillor i will now move
straight to debate as this is a motion
so i can see councillor molly's waiting
yes thank you councillor fleming spoken
and councillor eberner both spoken
really eloquently about the
the green space and the biodiversity
aspects of this motion um
it is well recognized that
mental health is a key
as well to physical health and so
green spaces for me are so
important in terms of our residents
health and well-being
so especially in our urban more urban
areas
um i am really keen to see um
what we can do to increase access to
open spaces for people in our
in our in our towns stone market and i
and debenham and
need a market because um it can
only contribute to our our
overall health and well-being i'm sure
others will be able to speak far more
eloquently about the health and
well-being aspects of that
but um i'm really happy to support this
motion
thank you thank you councillor morley uh
we're now moving to
councillor passmore please
thank you very much chairman uh i too am
delighted to support this motion
and i would like to echo what everybody
has said so far
um and it gave me cause to reflect on
how jolly lucky we are in mid-suffolk
most of us because we do live in such a
very pleasant
area and that does include most people
who live in the more urban parts of
um of our district and it gives me cause
to reflect as i was saying on
those who have had the misfortune during
lockdown let's say if you're a single
mum with two or three young children
10 floors up say in the middle of london
or any of our other great cities
how terribly terribly difficult it must
be for them so that brings into sharp
focus
the need for looking at this in a
pragmatic way for people's mental
well-being mental health physical
exercise all of these things come
together
so i think this opportunity for us as a
district to lead the way once again
um is very very welcome indeed and i
caused to reflect on that further i
delivered a package down to mcfield
today and came
back home like many of us do in suffolk
round the back
and it's incredible how much fresh
planting has been done by farmers and
others there and i hope
all of this will contribute to making um
mid-suffolk an even better place because
it is working with others as well it's
not just down to the district we can
help facilitate it
so i think if that's all included in
what we're doing as a review then
that's going to make us some a very good
place to live work
and travel in so i should be supporting
this up to the hill chairman
thank you guys more thank you uh
councillor richardson please
thank you chair um i wanted to follow on
from what uh councillor morley was
talking about
but actually if i can um make reference
to what she said at the end
i don't think i can put it or i don't
think any of us can put it more
eloquently than she did
um because i think she's absolutely
absolutely hit the nail on the head
that the um access to open green spaces
that's
the the sort of the driving force behind
this motion
is absolutely essential in terms of
improving people's health
and well-being be that physical health
in terms of access to open green spaces
for
exercise and activities that can
increase people's physical health
but also that access to to to open areas
um and to the countryside that inc that
can increase people's
mental health and well-being as well and
i think
um notwithstanding the other important
aspects of this motion
i think that's a really important
consideration as far as
um what we're debating and so i would
just
um thank councillors ebern and uh
fleming for their for their
collaborative approach in in putting
forward this motion and i'd absolutely
echo what counselor even said is i hope
we can all
support this motion and that it can be a
um unanimous vote
at the end of the day thank you chair
thank you and moving on to cancer
counselor mattison please
thank you chair yes i shan't repeat all
the all the um
very correct words that have already
been said what i wanted to do though was
to ask councillor byrne
um if if he will undertake
to to retain in our emerging joint local
plan
the designation of visually important
open spaces
because some of these absolutely fall
within the definition that we've been
discussing
and um it is often important in the
planning committee
to recognize these designations in
weighing up the balance
of difficult decisions and we have lost
so many small pieces
of nevertheless valuable
biodiversity um in in recent months and
years
and um so i think keeping that
designation would be very
helpful to supporting this motion
uh which i i of course do support thank
you
thank you and i'm sure that councillor
bernie's taking that point uh on board
thank you
uh moving on to council scarf please
thank you chair yes um i too would
welcome the motion i think it fits
perfectly with what we're aiming to do
regarding health and well-being our
contributions to climate change and
biodiversity
and indeed if passed tonight there are a
number of ways that we could pay for the
implementation of such a review
because we agreed various pots at our
last council meeting
and at least three of those pots could
be uh tapped to pay for it
um in terms of personal preference i
mean i think i would always prefer
for public realm to be heavily involved
uh
on our behalf rather than development
companies
in terms of estates so i'm straying into
if you like new development
but i think ultimately villagers and
residents and parishes if they have
control of their open spaces
that would be far more preferable um i
just wanted to comment on the
supplementary planning document that's
in preparation
because i think anyone who lives in an
urban area
such as such as mine would recognize
that we
do also actually have a need to ensure
that the green spaces
on new developments are actually
delivered they're often
a key reason why someone would move to a
new estate
is the green space that's allocated
within the
planning application but i have one in
my ward that's been fenced off for three
years
and is still not available for members
of the public on an estate which has now
completed its first phase
entirely so i think we do therefore need
to ensure
not just going forward but we also look
backwards in this review to ensure that
those
important urban green spaces are
actually delivered because i think if
any of our residents in
my ward um we're listening tonight
they'd go well it's all very well you
know it's all good but what about our
green space so we
we've got to encompass everybody's green
space and ensure that
that is delivered thank you thank you
sir councillor warboys please
thank you chair um yes i'd like to
speak uh in support of this motion
it does it indeed respond to local needs
and well-being
but it's also part of much wider issues
i'd like to draw members attention to
the dusk up to review
the economics of diversity published by
the treasury department
in february 2021
it demonstrates that in order to judge
whether economic development is
sustainable
we need to adopt a system of accounting
that is inclusive of
natural capital it also argues for a
paradigm shift from considering
ourselves masters of the planet
to recognize that we are embedded within
and dependent on the biosphere
this is clarified by guidance from the
department of environment
food and rural affairs in march
2020 they said
at its simplest a natural capital
approach
is about thinking of nature as an asset
or a set of assets that benefit
people and biodiversity can be thought
of as a core component
of natural capital with multiple effects
on social and economic welfare
perhaps uh the loss or gain of natural
capital
should perhaps carry more weight in the
balance sheet of development
and this motion is a step in the right
direction to evaluating our natural
capital
we certainly do not want to fall into
the trap of in the words of
the 70s johnny mitchell song
don't it always seem to go that you
don't know what you've got till it's
gone
i look forward to when the yearly
financial report of the council
includes not only how our financial
reserves have grown
but also how our carbon emissions have
reduced
and quite literally how our reserves of
natural capital have grown
thank you chair thank you councillor and
uh
councillor geek please
thank you chair um could i make a plea
for our green spaces whether that's new
or existing ones to be truly communal
and to be encouraged as meeting places
so that people can meet safely outdoors
specifically to combat loneliness and
isolation
they are essentially our outside living
rooms there are outside meeting spaces
and we should all be encouraged to use
them as much as possible
thank you thank you and
uh councillor byrne please
thank you jay i just wanted to
come back a little bit on what uh
councillor matheson was saying
about the um retention of
the visually important open space
designation in our
uh emerging joint local plan
i think council mathemate knows that the
time has probably passed
to reinstate that in the um
in the reg 19 version that will be
submitted for examination
but uh in these rapidly changing times
it is important i think that we consider
reviewing that um
uh that that uh joint local plan
well almost as soon as we uh as soon as
we adopt it so we can have done
quite a bit of work on the review now
it's perfectly possible
to reconsider the designation uh
of things such as a visually important
open space
um special landscape area etc etc
which have given way at the moment to a
different policy
policy framework um and to
the council of war boys i'm very
familiar with the not as familiar as i'd
like to be because it's 600 pages long
uh with the das gupta report and i think
it is a very very important um piece of
work that um
we all ought to be aware of and we all
ought to take it
take it to heart when we're thinking
about where we're going
how to plan for the future how to
incorporate
um by
um natural capital accounting into
everything that we do and i think that
includes planning as well
so um uh yes
uh we're moving in the right direction
on many of these things so
and and so far counselor geek is
concerned
um i hear what she's saying
but a different different open green
space
we can't have biodiversity in in
quantity
alongside human beings in quantity
the two don't go together there will be
green space
that should be set aside more more or
less for biodiversity
um but that doesn't mean to say that we
shouldn't be working hard
to create green space for for um
people as well so um i'm all for this
uh motion i think it's a very good step
in the right direction thank you very
much
thank you uh councillor welland please
thank you chair um yes of course i
welcome the motion
just one one thing that i'm a bit
concerned of and that is that open
spaces within you develop cert
developments are often problematic a
developer may try to keep the
um the provision of open space down to
an absolute minimum
and pass the open space on to someone
else as quickly as possible
local councils i speak as a parish
councillor
but i'm aware many other councils feel
much the same
they have a desire to make provision for
their residents
but often they don't have the necessary
expertise and resources
to maintain and to maintain and improve
the open spaces within their parishes
perhaps what is needed most to encourage
local councils
is access to free advice uh
free advice and funds so that they can
maintain them
i think open space is our best kept in
the hands of local groups not in
development management contractors and
one other thing i would ask
is could the review look at green spaces
which have poor access
um access for the mobility and visually
impaired
is essential and green spaces which are
not being satisfactorily maintained
and could they recommend how best to
improve access for all not
not on a specific basis but some general
advice to parish councils and the like
thank you
thank you councillor uh moving on to
councillor mellon please
yes thank you mr chairman um obviously
i'm supporting this motion and
um i think it's very important that we
have green spaces in our towns and urban
areas and we can look back
to some very far sighted people in the
past who
who in planning our towns and cities put
aside
um land for green spaces and and that is
some of our you know most historic and
and well-loved parks
um that are still here today but we also
need
um green space in the countryside and
that may seem strange you know
i live here in a village and we have
countryside all around us
but in actual fact there is very little
uh
open access countryside um
if you go to you know the national parks
or to scotland yes you can roam about
but obviously
here in mid southwest we live in a
largely farmed landscape
and we can't have people you know just
wandering willy-nilly through crops
or roaming their dogs on on fields you
know with sheep and that sort of
sort of thing so yes we have footpaths
we have bridal ways
and they're very useful but we also need
usable green space in the countryside
and we have some we have village greens
we do have some open space and we have
um i think in mellis one of the biggest
village greens in the country
um but we do need usable space and
um sometimes you know we see uh green
space in our planning applications and
it looks great and then when you dig
down into the detail
um it turns out to be an attenuation
basis which may or may not be accessible
often fenced off or it's green space
that's going to be under a management
company
and this deters everybody from using it
so um i support this and i very much
support the fact that we should try and
facilitate
our parish and town councils to identify
and get hold of green space
in the countryside as well
thank you councillor fl
flatman please thank you chair
we really are so lucky in mid-suffolk i
mean
you're talking about urban we don't have
urban here at all uh need a market
oh yes we're having quite a lot of
development need a market but all you've
got to do is just walk down the road
and you come to our lovely needham lakes
that we are investing
so much money in and we have made that
so accessible with our saving place
lose so that we can have schools there
um with special needs they can go in
there there's a hoist
um you know and the nature is there for
the schools as well so
i think mid suffolk district council are
doing
all they can to make sure everything is
accessible for people
and you know it i think we are so lucky
i mean
um we do have footpaths
i mean i live in the middle of nowhere
but i only have to step out the door
and there's people going down here in
their drones because they just got
footpaths all around
we have some fantastic footpaths so
i mean it doesn't take many i mean i
think you can walk probably 100 yards in
most places and nearly get onto a
footpath
so you know i think we are so so lucky
and we just have to make sure that we
keep these areas
um lovely for following generations
thank you chair
thank you uh moving on to councillor
carter please
uh thank you jeff yes we certainly are
extremely lucky
in mid-suffolk um
i don't know if i've actually muted
myself or ever press the wrong button
um yeah sorry
we certainly are lucky uh to be
not very urban area unfortunately not
the best
luck on uh accessibility a lot of
footpaths
aren't the most accessible um we are
extremely we are a
a preferable place right now for this
motion so that we can ensure
that all our green spaces are accessible
to all
that uh we have we can review the
biodiversity which
is surprisingly easy to have quite a
dense biodiversity and have it
with the people such things as clover
and which will be in the grass
daisies virtually to take down carbon in
its droves
and it actually they benefit from being
walked on so we can
ensure that we have the right plant
planting area we can ensure we have the
right
if a mix we can ensure that green spaces
that we have
are being managed correctly which we do
have areas which have the wrong
plants in invasive species such as in
stove warning we
have areas closed off which we're trying
to actually remove these out
so with this review we can ensure that
we get
we are put on the right track that these
are accessible for all and that's uh
even once planted up that they can
remain
healthy for generations to come so i
will definitely be supporting this
and we can finally start making up for
damages that have been
to bun past a couple of years thank you
thank you councillor anybody else wish
to come into debate we'll just uh give
you a couple of seconds
okay uh we'll go back to council ebon
would you like to add anything
um thank you very much chair yes if i
may i'd like to thank all my
colleagues um i'd like to say across the
chamber as it were virtually
um for their their comments and
contributions to this debate
um i think it's been very positive um
and at the beginning of my proposal i
gave seven reasons
for the importance of green spaces the
first being
um for physical and mental health
and i look forward to um seeing how this
aspect
can be incorporated into a future health
and wellbeing
strategy definitions of green space are
important but again
i'd leave that to our public realm and
planning policy colleagues
um to advise us of what will stand up
and under scrutiny
but ultimately with this motion we
really need to listen to our
communities um and to be able to provide
more accessible green space and enhance
those that we have
and i really look forward to a meeting
in the future where we hear
back um we hear a report showing that
all we
that we've all contributed to showing
how we've increased
this resource for the benefit of
residents and visitors alike
so thank you very much chair and i
hopefully everyone
support this motion thank you thank you
council eben
um so i'm now going to ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors the vote is
now open if you would like to place your
vote
thank you
chair that is a unanimous vote for thank
you
that is carried okay um so we've come to
the end of the meeting
thank you all for your contributions not
just tonight but in general
it is worth it it is important and it is
valued
whether you're an officer or whether
you're a counselor it all makes things
work
so thank you please keep it up the next
meeting
will be the annual meeting on monday the
24th
of may at 5 30 pm i look forward to
seeing you all there stay safe and thank
you again for tonight
you